hi there today we're looking at when
Bert plays the lottery all tickets are
winning by sigh Prasanna anna rogers and
on our room jiske so a high-level
overview of this paper is the following
the paper basically looks at Bert in
terms of the lottery ticket hypothesis
and it says that if you fine tune Bert
on different downstream tasks then the
lottery ticket winners you're going to
find are different between the tasks and
also the claim all tickets are winning
refers to the fact that if you remove
the winning tickets then you can still
train the rest to relatively good
performance therefore all tickets are
winning not just the subnetwork so that
was the high-level overview for those if
you just want to be interested if you
want to continue watching this video if
you do like videos like this consider
sharing liking subscribing telling your
mother father brother and friends about
it
alright let's dive in so Bert it is a
language model basically if you don't
know a birdís I've done a video on Bert
but really quickly what you can do with
Bert is you can take the sentence
something like hello there and you can
put it through this multi-layer neural
network and what you'll get out is
basically an embedding of that of that
sentence so a vector embedding of it
well make it really easy and what what
is usually done is this is pre trained
on a task called masked language
modeling this is unsupervised training
and then you take this embedding and you
fine-tune basically you put on a
classifier head basically say let's take
sentiment classification so you have to
output classes and you want to say is
this sentence I put in positive or
negative sentiment so you would train
this classifier by basically taking this
part from the pre trained mask
language modeling and then training the
part here that does the sentiment
classification you would sort of add
that on top and then fine-tune the
entire network to solve this task right
so that that is basically Bert
fine-tuning on different tasks and
there's this benchmark called
glue where it has a number of tasks in
this case I think they look at nine
tasks of glue it has nine of these tasks
would wanna see an example is the
sentiment classification and it
basically gets a score for each one and
thereby you can sort of estimate how
good your language model is by how well
it is performing on each of those
individual tasks but the notable
difference here to let's say a computer
is like an image net classifier is the
fact that first it is pre trained right
this part here is pre trained on a large
corpus and second there are different
downstream tasks that you fine-tune on
so the second part that is important is
the lottery ticket hypothesis so I've
also done a video on the lottery ticket
hypothesis and if you very quickly what
the lottery ticket hypothesis is the
following so let's say you have an image
classifier and I have a bunch of layers
in my neural network draw them like this
and at the end right I can classify it
into like ten different or a thousand
different classes whatever and the input
here is an image so my neural network is
going to have weights so every one of
these neurons is connected to each other
now this can be a convolutional at work
or a MLP so all is connected to all and
as well here right everything is
connected to pretty much everything so
we know first of all we know that we can
train these big networks to relatively
good accuracy and then second of all so
first we can train them
second we know we can prune them after
training
what pruning means is the fact that
after I have trained such a thing I can
then go and I can figure out which one
which of these connections that I have
learned are the important ones and maybe
I'll say ah these these here actually
these these five I don't need more than
those let's actually connect them to the
end these seven or so I don't need all
of the other ones I just need those and
I can pretty much get the same accuracy
as the full network now the important
part here is that you can only do
pruning after you've trained a network
if you try to prune at the beginning it
doesn't work so what the lottery ticket
hypothesis says is basically so how does
training work first you have your
parameters let's let's tell them as a
list so each of these weights is an
entry in the list here first you
initialize these randomly then through
training training you get to your
trained state right you get each of the
ones into your these are now trained and
in the train state you can select the
ones you think are important the lottery
ticket hypothesis says if I take those
that are important and basically go back
to the beginning like here here and here
and I basically roll them back to that
state that they were in when they were
initialized so I put the same random
number there that I got at
initialization I can then make a network
where I only have those I can train that
network and I can get a good accuracy so
what this this basically wasn't possible
in the pruning framework because we said
we can't prune we can only prune after
training because only then do we know
which ones are the important ones in
fact the lottery ticket hypothesis or
the paper shows that you can train the
smaller neural network from the
beginning but the catch of course is you
have to know which ones though
are and you have to know what value to
set them on at the beginning and you
only know that after you've trained the
full network but still it kind of gives
the it tells you that you don't need all
these connections for training you
basically only need so many connections
such that somewhere in there there's
going to be the good ones right and if
you knew the good ones from the
beginning you could just train those and
then only train the smaller sub Network
so that's the lottery ticket I pathes is
naturally these connections here this
small network is called the winning a
winning ticket because if you knew what
it was you could basically train a much
smaller network and reach the same
accuracy so this paper looks at Burt in
terms of this lottery ticket hypothesis
now it's a bit more complicated than
just in these feed-forward networks
because Burt is not a feed-forward
network Burt is a transformer so what
does that mean a transformer consists of
many layers and each layer let's expand
the layer here so each layer consists of
let's go over there need some space so
again we have our layers of Burt and it
goes signal goes like this so each layer
consists of two things first of all of
many attention heads that's called not
going to draw these as blocks right here
so for let's call them for attention
heads individual attention hats are all
parameterised by individual matrices and
then on top of that there is an MLP so
this is the multi-layer perceptron this
is one basically a feed-forward layer
residual actually and so there is a skip
connection right here
and these are the attention heads okay
and then the next layer would again have
the same structure for a face and then
one of these and so on with the skip
connection all right so the pruning in
burt is different than pruning in the
feed-forward or combo
was that we looked at pruning in bird to
what this paper looks at is pruning
either an entire attention head like
this so it's kind of leaving out in the
entire head away which is this is an
entire matrix this is not a single
weight right this is many many ways or
even more drastically leaving away an
entire MLP and basically only relying on
the skip connection all right so this
you have these two these two things you
can do you can leave away heads or you
can leave away entire MLPs or you can
combine these things in some way right
so the notable difference here to the
lottery ticket hypothesis pruning is the
fact that here over up here what we
prune are connections so prune
connections individual connections
individual connections and here we prune
entire modules now this is a in my
opinion this is a qualitative difference
a very large qualitative difference
actually why why would you do this so
this paper basically doesn't invent this
kind of pruning they go after already
existing literature so what's the
advantage in pruning modules well you
have to see what's the advantage in
pruning per se so in pruning what you're
trying to do is obtain a smaller network
that gives you the same accuracy but
then you can run faster right it uses
less memory and you can you can run it
faster and if you prune like this like
we did in the lottery takes it up
offices paper you don't really gain
anything because if you have a matrix if
you have a matrix matrix multiplied
right have two matrices and I multiplied
them right here if I if I cut out one
wait here or one wait here it doesn't
help me because I have GPUs and those
will paralyze these matrix procedures
and it doesn't really help me because we
don't really have good hardware for
sparse or
or matrix matrix multiplication or
matrix matrix multiplication with holes
or things like this so it almost gains
me nothing the lottery ticket hypothesis
paper is very much a kind of more of a
scientific curiosity paper and it once
we're have sparse matrix multiply
Hardware which I think it already exists
but is not super widely distributed once
we have that we will be able to make use
of this whereas the people that Probert
so these are more let's say industry
people if you prune an entire module
well that's an entire matrix that falls
away so I have to can I can basically
save an entire matrix matrix multiply in
the forward pass here on the and the
backward pass well okay I don't prove
here in training but I can basically
save an entire matrix multiply here by
pruning an entire module so I'm not sure
if if I were an author and I say I want
to look at bird in terms of the lottery
ticket hypothesis I would find a way I
would go away from this literature and
find a way to also just prune here
individual weights it's not gonna be
faster but the lottery ticket
investigations aren't supposed to be
faster they're supposed to tell you
something about the nature of the things
you're investigating and of course how
you do this is simply by masking right
you simply force these entries to be 0
and therefore you don't have forward
signal or you don't have gradient
interestingly they'd actually do the
masking but they do it on the whole
entire module level okay so this was
Bert and the lottery ticket hypothesis
and the all take 'its are winning we're
going to investigate later let's see
what they say in the abstract say much
of the recent success in NLP is due to
the large transformer based models such
as bird okay they say however these
models have been shown to be reducible
to a smaller number of self attention
heads and layers so this would be
pruning we consider this phenomenon from
deep
the lottery ticket hypothesis for
fine-tuned burped we show that here's
the contributions a it is possible to
find a sub Network of elements that
achieves performance comparable with
that of the full model so basically this
is the pruning objective read you want
to to prune it such that the performance
holds and in terms of the lottery ticket
hypothesis you want to prune reset to
the beginning and then also and then
train again and that will give you in
actually in the lottery ticket
hypothesis you can gain performance if
you prune by a certain amount in in this
case here they always lose performance
but yeah so
second of all similarly-sized
subnetworks sampled from the rest of the
model so that non winning ticket perform
worse so if you just really if you just
prune away the good parts then the bad
parts perform worse of course however
the Baths of networks can be fine-tuned
separately to achieve only slightly
worse performance than the good ones
indicating that most weights in the pre
trained bird are potentially useful so
this is interesting if they be
fine-tuned separately this is exactly
what the lottery ticket hypothesis is
doing right it's basically fine-tuning
only a sub part of the network and here
they say even if we take these so the
parts of the network that have low
scores for pruning and we retrain those
then we can achieve a good performance
okay so they further they say we also
show that the good sub networks vary
considerably across Glu tasks this is
this benchmark opening up the
possibilities to learn what knowledge
bird actually uses at inference time all
right so there this is the overview of
the paper so a last thing to say which
I've already kind of alluded to is the
fact
that in the original lottery ticket
hypothesis as I said you had a graph and
you had some sort of here was 100%
accuracy and here was how much you prune
you of course you start at 100% if he
prune nothing but then as you prune the
interesting thing is it kind of goes up
and then it goes down right so this is
the first thing here it goes up to a
certain amount
if you don't prune and in the original
lottery ticket hypothesis here somewhere
here would be 50% of the network I think
and then once you go down let's say here
to 90 percent of performance you are at
something like five percent of the
network size or three percent so you can
prune away most things and still be like
extremely extremely powerful now we're
going to see what these essentially what
these people do here is there is a
hundred percent and they simply prune
until they reach ninety percent so we
don't necessarily know what happens in
the middle we just know they they start
here and somehow they get to ninety
percent and what they end up with is
something like 50 percent of the network
still remaining so again see the
qualitative difference here between the
five percent of the lottery tickets in
the original paper and the 50-ish or so
percent or considerable amount more in
this paper right here and I'm pretty
sure that is due to the fact that they
prune entire modules here so they don't
prune on a fine-grained enough level to
investigate these phenomenon because as
I said we don't know but me I'm pretty
sure this just goes down here and not up
first so qualitatively it seems
different alright so here they
introduced what they do again earth is
contained is is made up of these
attention heads and MLPs the MLPs have a
skip connection as you can see here and
the attention had attention layers are
basically made of each
n of these attention pets what they will
do is there they will look at 12 layer
networks each layer will have 12 of
these attention heads and one of the
MLPs so you have in total one hundred
and forty four heads and twelve MLP
layers the way they determine which ones
to prune is pretty easy in front of each
attention head and in front of each MLP
they put one of these binary variables
right here these variables can take
values 0 or 1 if it's if they're 0 the
layers were the head is basically
inactive no propagation if they're 1
they are active and they determine what
value to set them to by computing
important source it's for determining
how important is a head or a layer for
the network and that's pretty simple is
employ take the gradient of the loss I
think they go after yeah they go after
this paper right here that's supposed
proposed following you derive the loss
by the
by these variables right here and
therefore you get these important scores
and then you can simply prune the layers
with the lowest important scores because
that means that the gradient with
respect to them is the smallest that
means your loss changes the least if you
were to leave them away okay so they
here determine their their pruning
strategy their constraint here is as I
said 90% of the performance of the full
model so they trained the full model
fine-tune the full model on this task
and then they they set themselves a
budget of 90% and they simply prune
until the model reaches 90% once it goes
lower they stop okay so they have three
methods of pruning one is heads only
where they only cut away these these
attention heads as I said there are 144
of them they have the pruning strategy
of MLPs only or they only prune them
apiece leave all the attention heads
alone and they have this heads and MLPs
they say we compute head and MLP
importance force in a single backward
pass pruning 10% heads and one MLP with
the smallest scores until the
performance on the deficit is within 90%
okay then we continue pruning heads
alone and then m/l peas alone and this I
guess until again they are no longer in
the 90% so until they reach their budget
they so this is a combined strategy this
strategy results in a larger number of
total components pruned within our
performance threshold so this is the
this is the thing we should focus on
right because in pruning the name of the
game is how much can you take away and
still be within your budget and this
strategy is seems to be the valuable
strategy here so a last thing here is
fine tuning so
the other difference between this paper
and the lottery ticket hypothesis is
that we said that in the original paper
here
these are randomly initialized weights
like you train a class for an image net
or something you start from randomly
initialized weights and the lottery
ticket papers they all they all kind of
presuppose a random initializations
whereas bert when you do the same thing
for Bert these are not random
initializations we said in Bert what you
usually do is you train the the encoder
part here you pre train with masked
language modeling first and then second
you train the entire thing let's get the
color here a second you train the entire
thing you fine-tune the entire thing so
if we talk about initializations
in the bird task then the initialization
would be at this point right here after
the masked language modeling would be
the initialization so the weights are
not random the weights are actually pre
trained on the masked language modeling
task which is also a qualitative
difference and sort of lets us inspect
so the authors say that since we trained
with mask language modeling and people
sort of claim that mask language
modeling learned something about the
language we can now investigate kind of
which attention has which modules in
Bert are encoding which parts of the
language and this is gonna be
interesting once we look at which heads
which attention heads and which modules
survive in the individual tasks we can
sort of compare tasks across each other
by seeing which of the heads they share
in their winning tickets all right so
they produce these graphs here these are
sort of one of these central graphs here
and the way to read this is on the left
side here you have the layer or oops you
have the layer index
and on the x-axis you simply have the
index of the head there are a hundred
and forty four boxes here each one
corresponds to one of the attention
heads the top number is always the mean
number of glue tasks that this head
survived in so what they do is they take
the pre trained bird
they fine-tune it on these nine tasks
and for each of the nine tasks they
determine the winning tickets right and
the number here says how many in how
many of these nine tasks is this
particular tension head a part of the
winning ticket now they repeat it for
different random seats that's why you
have floating point numbers and the
lower part is the standard deviation
across that so you can see quite a
number of heads make it into a lot of
these tasks so you can say this or this
thing right here are red on red this
head right here survives in seven out of
the nine tasks so it should be fairly in
it should
it probably encodes something fairly
substantial about language that is
shared across these seven tasks right
you can see some of the heads like this
one here doesn't survive in almost any
task which basically means that it's you
know that one's not really super
important for these tasks it might have
been you know important for the
pre-training but not for these
particular tasks what's interesting czar
what you can see is that the mean or
median or so is like three four or five
and that means that a lot of they're the
heads are sort of somewhat important for
some of the tasks and you can see the
qualitative difference if this were
these like original lottery ticket paper
most of these numbers would be at zero
because the lottery tickets size is just
so much smaller here you can directly
see that you are going to retain a large
number of things in your network in
order
to get 90% of the performance and that's
probably because you prune entire
modules again so they have this for two
variants here first for this strategy of
masking heads only and the right one is
for masking heads and MLPs
and the same here on the bottom these
are the same numbers but not for
attention heads but for MLP layers and
you see again this is masking ml fees
only this is masking heads and MLPs so
if you compare the so the two you see
that for example this here and this here
are substantially darker which means
more of this stuff survives now we can't
really it seems like here for example
there's it's darker than here so on the
right side more stuff survives but also
you have more things to prune right you
have you can prune the heads and the
MLPs
and they claim before that the masking
heads and MLP strategy results in more
things being pruned which doesn't really
isn't really congruent with here
generally more things surviving but it
could be because of the fact maybe the
sum of the two is still lower than the
sum of each individuals individual thing
here though it doesn't really look like
it so I'm bit confused about this but
I'm just going to assume that the sum of
the two is his is lower does that make
sense if both are darker well it
shouldn't be the sum it should be the
sum of this plus a completely dark this
in terms of masking heads only or vice
versa versus the sum of those two right
so that should be the measure but it
just seems a bit a bit doesn't work out
too much but okay that's what they say
so by the way if the offers are here you
have the this is cut off
um yeah this is annoy this is like
trying to get a lot of tech to do things
and it doesn't comply alright so what
you can another thing you can see the
authors point out here is that if you
mask heads and MLPs you sort of shift
more things to the back of the network
to the higher up layers and they reason
now because you also mask the heads he
basically they can't do as much work so
you so the heads would be masked
somewhere here so all that work is going
to shift on the MLPs and mostly to the
back of the network because this thing
here cannot take over work that this
attention head here is now not
performing any more because it was
pruned because the signal travels this
way so the authors kind of interpret
these results right here and I think the
most important thing to see is simply
the variance of things so most heads are
actually important for at least two or
three tasks and no head is important for
all the tasks consistently I think
that's the take-home message right here
okay and they contrast this to previous
research that has basically said his
experiments follows up on study by this
that showed that only a few transformer
heads in machine translation tasks did
the heavy lifting while the rest could
be pruned and this paper similarly
showed that most of bird self attention
head in MN li tasks could be pruned and
that the good heads were mostly shared
between the M and L I matched and
mismatched and they basically say yeah
that's correct but there's only within
one task right if you go beyond if you
go to several tasks then the heads that
are important differ quite a bit okay so
let's continue and go here
they ask how tasks independent or the
good softener works and they basically
look at these kinds of graphs right here
which are pretty interesting
so we've got this this is heads shared
between tasks so what this measures is
these are the different tasks in the
glue benchmark and they basically look
at each task look at its winning lottery
ticket and look at which heads survived
in the winning ticket and then they put
that here on the diagonal so if in queue
and a lie ahead survives it gets a 1
here and if it doesn't survive it gets a
0 so on average 85 out of the 144 heads
survive right 85 had survived that
that's pretty as I said this is some
somewhat like over 50% of the network
it's entirely different than the
original lottery ticket hypothesis paper
so 85% not percent 85 of the 144 heads
survive now they look at the other tasks
so for Q and a lie they would look at
maybe MN li tasks here and ask which of
the heads that survived in Q and a lie
also survives in M and L I so that gets
you the shared heads and again the lower
numbers of standard deviation so sixty
two heads are survived in Q and a lie
and MN a lie and the the authors here
are sort of arguing that from these sort
of numbers you should be able to see
which of the tasks share different
different linguistic knowledge so
different linguistic knowledge could be
relevant for the four different tasks
but if some tasks share a lot of the
attention heads that survive in the
winning tickets that basically means
that the model is using that information
that is in that head for both tasks this
could be good in that you say oh yeah
these tasks really or you
similar linguistic features or it could
be something that you don't expect and
then you might be able to investigate
maybe the model is doing something shady
here because it really shouldn't
shouldn't you know these tasks don't
really have much in common so they do
this for the heads and the ml piece here
now the if you ask why the wnl I hear
has a bunch of zeros that's because it's
a wonky task and basically the best
thing you can do is predict the most
frequent class so you can prove just
about anything away and these ml piece
because they have the skipped
connections you don't need them to
predict the the the most frequent class
what I want to go into is the following
statement right here so note that figure
one so the figure before shows very few
heads or MLPs
that are universally useless only seven
heads that survived in less than two
tasks eighty-six percent of heads in
same 67 percent of MLP survived in two
to seven tasks with a relatively high
standard deviation
they say this means that the good
subnetworks for different tasks have
relatively little in common right so
they make this they make this sort of
statement again here that these the
liquid softener networks have little in
common and it might seem like that for
for the for the figure initially but if
you look in this figure it actually
shows something pretty interesting I
think so if you look at a number let's
say for example this here this 74 and I
haven't actually tried yeah let's look
at the 74 and this seven is here so
let's look at these tasks q QP and RTE
okay
so if you look at qqp and RTE you could
see that these are tasks that already
they don't have a lot of heads in common
right and you might be able to say well
if what they're saying is true that the
tasks share relatively little you would
expect them to be relatively independent
but if I look at this 78 here it means
that 78 out of 144 heads survive and
here it means that 74 out of 144 heads
survive so if I now would think that ok
generally for different tasks things are
different how many heads would I expect
there to be surviving in both if the
tasks are independent so that's these
two things multiplied right times 144 so
I can scratch this here and the 7 times
7 is whatever 49 let's go 7 times 8
about this so that's five six do I need
to get out the calculator I want to I
want to do this calculator sugar bean or
do this right way okay I hope you can
see that so that's 78 times
74 divided by 144 did I do it right
probably did it wrong I do like 78 times
74 divided by 144 all right so that's 40
heads and you see that there's 43 heads
and I've actually gone through a bunch
of these numbers before not these ones
but generally the shared number of heads
is higher than what one would expect if
you assume that the tasks are
independent and um I'm sort of missing
sort of an analysis of that here because
that I found to be a pretty
interesting finding of these things and
sort of I mean I get I get the fact that
they say based on the graphics up here
that the tasks are sort of seen to be
relatively independent with respect to
the heads that survive and of course
relatively independent is a relative
term but a sort of an investigation into
why we see considerable dependence
between tasks here in terms of that so
relative these numbers are always over
the what you would assume for
independence that seems to be pretty
interesting alright so they say they
here go into this figure two and it's
pairwise comparison and they analyzed a
couple of the different tasks here and
what you would expect and and I don't
want to go too much into these aspects
of honestly I so I also don't know all
of these tests I don't know which tasks
should share a lot of things which ones
shouldn't but it is a good way like it
is a very smart way to investigate if
the model really learns similar tasks to
use similar information alright the last
thing they do right here is the good and
the bad sub networks invert fine-tuning
so they say our final experiment puts
the above evidence of goods of networks
in third fine tuned from the perspective
of lottery ticket hypothesis which
predicts that the locus of networks can
be retrained from scratch to match the
performance of the full network to test
this hypothesis we experiment with the
following sub networks so that means um
I wasn't really sure when I read it the
first time but now I'm fairly sure that
all of the results so far were just
pruning and maybe not retraining so just
sort of doing the pruning thing and not
doing this lottery ticket
retraining which shouldn't make a lot of
the difference as
we're going to see but just for the
understanding because it seems like
pruning and retraining doesn't doesn't
do that much for the winning tickets as
you'll see right now but yeah so now
they actually retrain from scratch so
good networks the elements selected from
the full model by important scores as
described in the tree like in the
previous section so here they're going
to evaluate these good networks first of
all they're going to evaluate them
pruned and they're going to evaluate
them retrained in the lottery ticket
style okay
then they're also going to evaluate bad
sub networks the elements sampled from
those that did not survive the pruning
plus a random sample of elements with
high importance score such so as to
match the size of the good sub networks
so because the good sub networks are 50%
or more of the network they they want to
they're going to sample from the things
that did not survive so from the bad
ones and they post a random sample of
the goods of networks to just match the
size okay so we would expect these to
perform maybe worse but maybe we can
also train them to achieve good
performance and then they investigate
bad sub networks simple inversion of the
good sub Network so this would be just
anything but to good they are 5 to 18
percent smaller in size than the sampled
bad sub networks but they do not contain
any elements with high important scores
and they say ok for all of them they
evaluate their performance on all tests
simply after pruning and with fine
tuning the same sub network with the
same random seeds and with the rest of
the modeled masks so this is really what
the lottery ticket hypothesis does
except they of course mask entire
modules and not individual weights and
here you can see the general results
so the general results look like
something like this this is a tip
Pikul example so this is the let's go
out oh yeah
this here is simply the dumb classifier
that always tells the the highest
probability class this is the like this
is sort of the the idiots baseline okay
this here is the full model fool this
here is the good pruned and this here is
the good after it's retrained again okay
so you see by a retraining you can basic
again the original lottery ticket this
would sometimes even go up here
depending on how much was pruned but you
can see that there is a slight gain
after you retrain the pruned part okay
and the other thing to note here is that
you don't lose much basically you you
only drop a little bit by pruning which
that's what makes it the good part
you only drop a little bit however if
you have the bad part which are these
and let's say the good plus bad these
are the bad plus some of the good ones
you see that the performance drops
pretty heavily almost to the the
baseline of of the most frequent class
and also here so I would actually I
would go with this one right here if
because that's just the bad ones you see
the performance drops considerably but
then and that's what the authors claim
is pretty interesting
if you retrain that part the bad part
so to say you can achieve sort of a very
comparable performance to what you can
achieve with the good parts and this
appears to be true for most of the
results right here there are some
outliers like this one but they're the
score is also so this is the Matthews
correlation and not the an accuracy so
the score is a bit different there but
you can see here the good plus bad also
gets a fairly high accuracy
all right so the offers claim this is um
pretty surprising which I guess it is if
you look at this but what I want to do
is I actually want I have asked the
author of the lottery ticket hypothesis
this question so this is from our
machine learning Street talked with
Jonathan Franco and this is another
channel that I am my part of and I would
like to show you this right here when
when I asked him this question not a
question from reddit M Nemo asks suppose
you try to construct a lottery ticket by
taking all the weights that were not
part of a winning ticket and Retraining
from those will that model be unable to
learn the task or might there be another
winning ticket hiding among them or one
one that wasn't originally used so this
is the most common question I get by
people who read the original paper and I
I hope that by answering it here in a
public forum I can answer it once and
for all
the challenge in doing this experiment
is let's take the amnesty example so
suppose that we find a winning ticket on
M NIST it's going to be about three
percent of the original size of the
network so that means that if you remove
it you've still got 97 percent of the
weights left and so my guess is that if
you were to train those 97% of weights
you'll get to the same accuracy as you
got with a hundred percent of weights
because you've barely proven the network
at all you could randomly prune by three
percent it wouldn't affect it and then
you could go and find another lottery
ticket that's mutually exclusive with
the first you still have 94 percent of
the weights and you could probably
iterate this for a very long time
probably you know you could you could
probably this way find you know ten
fifteen lottery tickets like this maybe
more that are all mutually exclusive and
still leave you with a remaining kind of
residual that is capable of training to
full accuracy so the challenge with this
experiment is that the lottery tickets
are small which is great but it means
that whatever is left is large enough
that you know I'm sure there's another
lottery ticket in there and another
lottery ticket in there and so on and so
on and so on so it's a it's a it's an
interesting idea in principle but once
you kind of look
the sizes of things you've still got so
much over parameterisation left that I
think you'd you just find more lottery
tickets you can even probably I'm
guessing swap out one weight from a
lottery ticket with another weight and
it wouldn't matter or swap out a handful
of weights and so combinatorially the
number of lottery tickets is massive and
we're just finding one all right so as
you saw this is kind of the most common
question that that Jonathan gets here
and as you can see the difference here
of course is that our original tickets
are already sort of 50% of the network
so what's left is only 50% so this is
substantially different now two things I
have to remark here first of all if if
because because we are pruning modules
and not individual weights for the good
one it's the reason that we do get these
um these big winning tickets right but
also what I think is happening is that
in because we are pruning these entire
modules we're actually not fine-grained
enough so that means every time we
eliminate a module we actually kill some
good ones and some bad ones and so in
here I'm gonna guess there are some good
ones and there are some bad ones but
since we can only kill entire modules
you know we sort of we simply kill the
one that on average has the most good
ones but I'm guessing that in the thing
we kill there are simply there sorry we
kill the one that has on average the
least good ones but there are still some
good weights in there and if you believe
the original lottery ticket hypothesis
that means that these actually these
very few weights in those modules can
still train to full accuracy so the
actually what what these authors claim
is surprising in light of the original
lottery ticket hypothesis I think if you
look at it from the perspective of the
actual hypothesis which considers
individual weight and the you know a
very small subset of them the original
hypothesis would would pretty much
predict that you could train something
where you pruned away a bunch of modules
entirely or you can train these bad
modules because they are still going to
contain a small sized lottery ticket
that is going to be responsible for the
good performance so that's the kind of
the first thing and the second thing in
general you heard Jonathan I don't think
that is actually even a question of the
size of the tickets nothing in the
original hypothesis forbids the non
winning ticket from also being trained
to good accuracy that it simply says
something about the winning ticket it
doesn't say anything about the non
winning ticket so those are the two
comments and I I think the the question
and the investigation even though it is
interesting I think is sort of maybe not
thought through at least in the
perspective of they of what they go for
here I mean it is the result is very
interesting but again I think they claim
the original hypothesis would sort of
say these are the bad parts and you
couldn't train them and then they say
it's surprising that you can but I would
say that the original hypothesis would I
would in fact predict that you could
train those things because you've proved
away the entire modules which is very
coarse-grained and that leaves that
leaves still good weights in the bad
parts okay so they conclude however we
can see that both good and bad networks
can be retrained with comparable
performance on many for many tasks the
inverted bad networks perform worse than
the sampled ones but that could be due
to them being smaller in size
performance of all inverted bad networks
on coal is almost zero Daria
okay yeah okay very little remains when
that mask is inverted that's the task we
we looked at
because they claimed that so small which
makes sense right so discussion say it
is bad have just burped have bad
sub-networks the key result of this
study is that as far as fine tuning is
concerned birth does not seem to have
bad sub-networks that cannot be
retrained to relatively good performance
level suggesting that the way that do
not survive pruning are not just in
active however it is important to
remember that we consider elements of
bird architecture as an atomic units
while the original lottery ticket work
relied on magnitude pruning of
individual weights so that I mean
they're they're well aware here of these
of these differences which and they can
see to that right here so that's good on
that level bird probably does have bats
of networks and you show that can be
found in the transfer model with global
iterative pruning we leave it to future
research to find out to what extent the
effect of soft networks overlap with the
effective architectural blocks and what
that says about the architecture of bird
and the other transformers so as you see
that they're not they're well aware that
that all of what I said
is the case so it's not it's not like
I'm criticizing and saying they're wrong
it's just that if you read it you sort
of get the impression that this is what
they're saying and I think the the light
of which the reader goes through it is
just a bit such that such that you come
off if you don't read until here you
come off thinking something else
our result suggests that most
architecture blocks of bird are
potentially usable in fine tuning this
should not be interpreted as proof that
they all encode potentially irrelevant
linguistic information that's absolutely
true
yeah it is also possible that
pre-training somehow simply made them
more amenable to optimization which is
another question for future research and
they go into what do different bird
components do in the different things so
again I think the this worker is
actually most relevant for investigating
this question what do Bert
components the different bird components
do for the different tasks to look which
tasks use which things and the the
actual recognition that none of these
attend none of these modules is useless
I would consider pretty pretty cool
finding okay so in conclusion they say
prior work shows it was possible to
prune most self attention as we extend
this to 40 connected layers we shall
function versus good and bad sup
networks where the good heads in the
movies alone reached performance
comparable with the full network and the
bad ones do not perform well
however this pattern does not quite
conform to a lottery ticket hypothesis
both good and bad networks can be
fine-tuned separately to reach
comparable performance we also show that
86% of heads and 15% know he's in good
sub networks are not universally useful
across glue tests and overlap between
good and sub networks do not necessarily
correspond to task types so that's
that's where they that's why we didn't
go into this raises questions about the
degree to which fine to invert relies on
task specific or general linguistic
knowledge and opens up the possibility
of studying the good self networks to
see what types of knowledge bird
actually relies on at inference time so
this is sort of future research
direction and with that I think we've
gone through the paper I hope you got
something useful out of this I think
it's a pretty cool paper it's a pretty
cool methodology and I think a lot of
work can build upon this to do
interesting analysis of these language
models again if you like this video
consider sharing it subscribing liking
and bye bye